Serena Williams gears up for baby number  one by celebrating with a blast from the  past that was really fun  [Music]  the mama-to-be he was joined by her  sister Venus and some of her closest  famous friends including Ciara Kelly  Rowland and Eva Longoria on Saturday for  a 50s themed baby shower the ladies were  all dolled up in polka dots and  ponytails for the occasion the 35 year  old tennis pro stunned in a bright  yellow poodle skirt in black long-sleeve  crop top she paired the look with a red  bandana pearls and saddle shoes her  adorable bump on full display Serena and  her fiance Alexis Ohanian are expecting  their first child together later this  year and just last month alexis couldn't  seem to contain his excitement over  becoming a first-time father I'll be  taking off for six weeks myself that's  great and trying to do my best but the  best job possible as a new dad  first-time dad  [Music]